foreign
if you live at the center of a global
conservation spotlight
but you have no voice
your aspirations are not valid and your
knowledge does not count
sadly this happens very often in local
communities of key ecosystems around the
world
in conservation my field of work I call
it community-based conservation washing
which is basically when conservation
organizations claim to work for
communities only to inform and impose
pre-designed conservation plans instead
of including them misguiding media and
funding sources think of greenwashing
and then apply it to conservation
hopefully we can all agree that approach
is not right and it needs to be tackled
and how about we start by twisting
classic community-based conservation
questions upside down say instead of
wondering how to bring science and
policy to communities How about if we
find a way to bring the voice and
Centenary knowledge of communities to
research and policy making
but see the answer to such questions is
never a one-size-fits-all solution
because it needs to be tailored to the
unique environmental social and economic
realities of each community
let me give you some context I get to
work in one of the most incredible
Wetland systems on Earth
the sources of the cavango Zambezi
transfer tier Conservation Area Casa for
short
but now Casa spreads through five
countries and is home to iconic African
Wildlife incredible Landscapes like the
okavango Delta and up to 2.5 million
people
its sources in eastern Angola are the
heart the lungs and the backbone of the
entire Casa yet they're unprotected
in one of the many research trips I've
done to the area I met Mama laroccio the
oldest lady of a luchazi village and she
was genuinely surprised to still see me
alive
she told me the story of the mukisi this
mythical giant snake-like creature that
protects the rivers and thus life
and she told me that if the mukisi
spared me my life after spending four
months in Dugout canoes from the sources
Studio cavango Delta in Botswana it
meant he trusted me and if you did so
could they to luchazi people
but see most Lucchesi children do not
know of the mukisi or any other local
Tale and that is because the 40-plus
year long War they have endured has
created a gap in storytelling and has
stripped the way ownership of their
heritage
so now the ancient wisdom which is key
to stewardship is locked in the older
disappearing Generations
and so we started this journey to bring
back these stories as an effort to
restore pride and ownership oral
storytelling has always played a
fundamental role not only in African
culture but in conservation efforts too
we also do mapping exercises to help
villagers visualize the influence and
impact not only of their land but also
of their daily actions beyond their
Geographic reach to give them a sense of
importance to counteract how they felt
abandoned all these years
and we also help give them back the
power of decision by instigating
Curiosity on alternative livelihoods
that they can trial on all of this in an
effort to bring back ownership of their
Heritage and make them stewards of their
own land and also of their own future
but see through the years that trust
that I've mentioned before grew stronger
so now they scold me they teach they
feed they protect me they tell me
secrets of their Traditions children
tease me and call me names but I will
never be one of them
and thirsty will never fully truly trust
me
but that is the point of this whole talk
they're not supposed to trust me you or
anyone else coming in with a grand plan
to save the world they're supposed to
trust themselves
real community-based conservation goes
much Beyond ensuring an elder has a
ceremonial seat at the table and is
interviewed
it Fosters Fierce Independence doesn't
further dependency lasting conservation
comes from within from believing from
belonging from dreaming
so whether you are a conservationist
yourself for a donor or a media Outlet
or maybe just plain curious let's be
vessels for that for stewardship for
ownership for pride
don't just take the boxes ask the
difficult questions and always wonder
are we working for communities
or with communities
thank you
[Applause]